eager to experience a spectacular
sunrise at Cambodia's ancient Angkor Wat
here's everything you need to know to
get to this iconic site and make the
most of your visit Angkor Wat is
actually just one of over a thousand
temples that make up the ancient city of
Angkor today the entire city is a unesco
world heritage site
but Angkor Wat remains the most well
known and largest of all the anchor
temples this site can often be found on
travel must-see lists and no time of day
is more impressive than sunrise getting
here is easier now than ever but there
are a few key things you need to know in
order to travel to Cambodia you'll need
to get a tourist visa either online in
advance or at the airport in phenom penh
Siem Reap or at any major border
crossing the visa costs 37 US dollars
and is valid for a stay up to 30 days
fly into Siem Reap the gateway city for
all Angkor exploration it's located just
four miles south of the site and is a
destination in itself with plenty of
quality dining cultural and
accommodation options getting between
siem reap and angkor is surprisingly
simple if you're up to it you can
actually even walk there but if you're
looking to arrive in time for sunrise
you'd be best to arrange other
transportation the archeological Park
opens early at 5 a.m.
renting a tuk-tuk is a popular option
for under 30 US dollars you can have
your own personal driver who will pick
you up from your hotel take you to the
perfect sunrise spot and get you from
Temple to Temple throughout the day
just be sure to bring a bunch of smaller
US Dollars for cash tips along the way
guided us tours of the site can also be
arranged in Siem Reap or see it through
a NatGeo lens with one of several
National Geographic expeditions that
include a stop at Angkor Wat tickets to
access the entire park are available in
1 3 and 7 day passes ranging from 37 US
dollars to 72 US dollars a three-day
pass will give you plenty of time to
experience other notable landmarks
including the bayon temple of smiling
faces the to prom temple which was used
in the filming of the movie tomb raider
and sunset at pnom became having a
three-day pass also means that you can
escape back to your hotel room to avoid
the afternoon heat local temperatures
can exceed 100 degrees Fahrenheit during
the summer months the heat is extra
daunting since this is a sacred site and
there are no uncovered knees or
shoulders allowed and if avoiding the
heat isn't enough to entice you to visit
at sunrise these photographs will surely
do the trick
[Music]
you